Let's talk about
all this
cancel culture
and stuff
that you've been writing a lot about.
What I want to ask you is,
is it
particularly troubling issue for you
as a comedian?
Because, I mean, at some level, isn't
isn't every joke in some way offensive
Yeah, you're right.
You're trying to hate you.
I mean, absolutely not.
For every comedian, most comedians
don't go near anything that's offensive.
It's just not the way they work.
It's just not it's
not the kind of material
that interests them.
They're talking about other things.
Me? Yes.
This is
obviously
has always been an issue with me.
And
it's
but it's not just
people in show business,
not just such as famous people anymore
who worry about cancel culture.
There are a lot of people,
I don't know,
going through their high school
yearbook, like,
oh, my God, did
I wear a sombrero and
the prop or something?
And I mean,
lots of regular
people have been canceled for things,
you know, some guy says.
I don't know, just just
something he thinks is innocuous.
It's he doesn't know
He's saying,
well, white lives matter, too,
and he doesn't quite understand.
He's not of that generation
why we want a particular focus,
because black lives
have always been more at peril.
There's a reason
why that was a saying
and became an organization.
And he gets canceled.
Nobody just sat down and said, hey, hey,
this, this, this.
And he might I went, Oh, okay. I get it.
No, you're just gone.
That's what
people are just very tired
of walking on eggshells in this country.
That is something
the Democrats are also fighting
in this election. People don't like it.
And, you know, this is also part of why
Elon Musk taking over
Twitter is just such
an enormous controversy
with so many people.
And 99% of Twitter employees
voted Democratic.
Even if you're a Democrat,
you shouldn't think that's a good thing.
To have a major
what really is a news organization,
because people get their news from the
but from someplace
where the entire
organization thinks one way.
That's the very definition of groupthink.
Part of the problem is
we are sorting ourselves
into these two tribes
and it feels like college education
and urban rural are the two big dividers
where maybe religion would be the third.
So you get these urban,
college educated,
secular people on one side
and you get rural,
more religious
less and less college education.
And there's just so much tribal
suspicion, hostility,
you know,
it feels as if
it's not really about issues anymore.
You know, it's
no, I keep
trying to tell people who,
you know, don't even want to breathe
the same air as a Trump voter.
Like you can hate Trump
you can't hate
all the people who voted for him.
It's half the country.
And on top of that,
I really believe I have always believed
being conservative
is a personality
trait before it's a political position.
It's just something that's very innate.
You know, think of some uncle you had.
He was a great guy.
You loved him, but he was just a concert.
It was just in his blood.
Like, some people are neat
and some people are messy
and some people are adventurous
and some people are cautious.
It's just a personality.
And then the politics comes in later.
That's some of it has to do with religion
and where you live in the way
you were brought up and stuff like that.
But I mean,
there are just people
who are going to be conservative
and you're going to have to live
with them.
You can't own them or destroy them.
They're not going to self-deport
and they're about
to take over the government
so they're not going to give it back.
So what is going to happen
is let's assume both houses
go go Republican, where there's
this is what I was saying
at the end of my show Friday.
I felt the audience was
stunned, as they should be,
but they shouldn't be
because it's been going on
for a long time.
And I've been saying it for a long time.
Yes.
I mean, unless there's a
oddity with the polling
and it's going to be a very good day
for the Republicans,
as we both have mentioned,
the majority of Republicans
running for Congress,
for Senate, for House
and for statehouses,
the people who are going to decide
who is the president in 20, 24
are election deniers.
They don't believe in this crazy idea
that the guy with the most vote wins.
So what happens in 2024 is Trump
is going to try the coup
he tried in 2020
which was plainly an attempted coup.
There's no other way to look at it
but this time he's going to have in place
this army of deniers who will support him
and he is going to show up Robert to do.
I will bet every money
bit of money I have he will show up
on inauguration day on 2025
whether he's the winner or not.
And then we'll see what happens
and then we'll see how much we look like
other countries that we thought
oh that could never happen to us.
Yeah, it could and that could.
And he may have
thousands of people with arms as he did.
January 6th.
You think they're going to stay home
now that
this has happened again
and they have all these people in
place that are on their side?
Oh, no, my friend.
It's going to be very interesting.
On that cheery note, Bill,
I wish I had better news to report,
but you asked me.
Thank you for doing that. Right?
My pleasure. Always.